oh i i was thinking when you were saying
they locked the door and they were
asking you in the room
what happens like now today they can
listen with like
telescopic radio and and listen to
people talking in their houses
on a window how difficult it is to get
the information around
when the government goes haywire it's
getting more it seems like it's getting
more difficult
maybe it's getting easier too in some
ways that i don't know
underground it's all social media now
called away chair
you have groups so you have to be
careful in china
and people um i don't know what they do
with their cell phones when they talk
about sensitive stuff
because everything can be tracked by
your cell phone so chinese government
even
banning cash law every financial
transactions
is your cell phone when you go get your
cell phone brand new cell phone
the cell phone company which is the same
by governmental they scan your face
look at your voice recording then give
you the number
then hook up with your bank account and
now
your vaccine record vaccine passport
sounds familiar
so everything is on your cell phone
everybody has a cell phone it's very
cheap to get
then they built 4g 5g network all over
the country
300 300 million
public facial recognition cameras
in public places in china today in a few
years would be 600
million for every two citizens in china
you have one camera watch you and those
are huge cameras not like a little
traffic camera as you saw here
huge i saw them before and they are in
xinjiang
the weaker place everywhere watch people
you could not even talk to your
relatives overseas without somebody next
to you
listening say what you're saying so it's
a
people always say why chinese just
comply i said well
first of all the government propaganda
got lots of people in the cities
brainwashed some even think
social credit system is good for the
society
all the bad behaviors are gone but
how about citizens voices
how about dissidents voices ah doesn't
matter
you know so if your social critic school
system
your score is low you cannot buy train
tickets to travel
forget about flying forget about get
your passport leave the country
and your kids cannot even go to good
schools you cannot get the mortgages
and you cannot even say something on
your website because you can't work shut
down
hey sounds familiar in america you
self-censor
all the time don't say anything then you
will get shot down
or you score below you cannot get a job
your kids cannot get the health care
benefits
cannot go to good school now they're
forcing people
getting vaccinated and everybody
has to no exceptions and uh
i i some people will cross the
firewall which is the internet blocker
use a vpn
and watch my video interviews
maybe hopefully they will watch this one
too and they will tell me really
please tell americans don't let america
to becoming like china because we have a
hope in china
if america is free and you tell them you
tell them
don't become like us you speak for us
voiles people in china
every time when i get a message like
that i'm just like so move touched
it gave me more courage to continue to
speak up
in the same way i do here so you you
came to america
and it was a lot better and you had a
you you got married you had kids
you had a good life at what point did
you start to see the signs
in america that was similar to what was
happening with the communist party in
china
i was very naive when i first came to
this country i feel so happy
so free even though i did not have money
did not speak english
i just focus on school english culture
and
of course dating jiang we got married 18
months later
once we got married we focused on our
graduate degree we finished graduate
degree took him back to china i was
pregnant with our first son boom boom
boom since happened very quick so
guess what happened you got to make
money after graduation you got to get
jobs
so you have to get the jobs and raise
kids and
for 20 years i was not political
i just wanted to live in peace in
and trying to achieve my american dream
my husband had a student loans
we were even sent to hong kong work
there for two years and he paid off all
his student loans with my help
i got a full-time job too doing
international trade in hong kong
1996 to 98 i love hong kong
it's so sad what happened today but then
i come back to this country what
happened is my american dream
got interrupted i got laid off by
corporate work
i was in telecom industry 2000 collapsed
so i got layoff and we had a big house
mortgage to pay
our you know dream house with three kids
i started my business i always wanted to
be self-employed
so but my first eight years not
profitable
but that gave me time to study english
totally get involved i said well since
i'm american city now
i better learn how this democracy works
so i start to read i start to go to hoa
meetings
i become like a board member of hoa
charter school board member
later chairwoman a fire principal
on my watch and still i wasn't
threatened
until i go to state capital to become
student inter
for free to learn how state capital
state government is running
and i saw all the people there asking
for
taxpayers money all special interest so
i told my husband
i was kind of depressed today i went
there
nobody represent us middle class working
man woman who pay taxes risk family
all special interests lots of
bureaucrats they're representing
their special interest organizations
government
agencies but i still was focused on my
business
tried to make money i got even involved
2009 in real estate
the only reason i woke up is uh i was
independent for many years
i become republican and around 2008
when crash happened with when they when
banks were bail out i got really upset
free market field now we need to build
the banks
tarp money remember the bailout and that
all the patriot
act start to track american citizens
privacy it's like oh something's not
right here
and i start to have better english read
the books
and study history and i even read this
book really open up my mind called
free to choose free market economics
milton friedman
then later you know the evidence struck
it's like all that just i never heard
this ideology before
only no two parties i only the
government do some government do this
government help us i never thought about
there were other options
it's called free market a free
enterprise and private charity
and the private community individual
help each other
so i start changing i start to go into
some
different kind of meetings and then the
more
i got involved with politics the more
scared i become
why why are people using marxist terms
in this country
why are they talk about government
should be bigger and bigger
and the free stuff give people free
stuff and turn people renowned
government
you know how dangerous that is when you
renounce government
they take everything away overnight they
enslave you
they track you you do what i say oh what
don't give you food
i don't give you health care i don't
give you schooling
so i become more libertarian say oh we
need to have a bigger individual smaller
government
so i started getting more active in
politics my first time testified
ever it was colorado state house
they tried to ban our magazines limited
magazines
for ar-15s so i wonder testify 2013 even
wrote my
first opinion piece published to say
we don't want this here otherwise look
determine
square massacre maybe people will fight
instead get killed run over by
government we cannot compromise the
second amendment
that's the first time i testified and
but then
they passed anyway party night so i
become liberty activist
ever since 2014 i run for state house in
colorado
and i got involved with libertarian
party because i left the republicans
when they upsetted me when they left me
i saw they left me they left their own
platform behind
and i just care about our liberty i
don't care about all those politicians
rhetorics
that i run again 2016 because 2016
running for u.s
and senate gave me unlimited time to
talk about my stories
to get interviews like this in colorado
and
i thought wow actually whenever i go
tell my stories people give me big hands
i need to do more of this they obviously
want to know more about my stories what
happened to us
so i volunteered to be speaker in the
classrooms
for middle school high school college
students so i had a sponsor called the
victims
of communism memorial foundation based
in dc
i'm on their speakers bureau so students
teachers principals could request or we
need eyewitness of communism
from china to speak to us then boom i
will fly there
go to the classroom teach students it
was so
satisfying when i saw students eyes
open up like this like i did
when i was a senior like a junior year
in college
when i heard those new concepts right
our
students don't know much about horrors
of communism
that's why they're also our schools
are one side dominating they do not
teach you all kind of ideology for you
to choose
no how many students heard about
libertarianism how many students have
heard about other philosophers
it's all about marxism now divide and
conquer they don't use
marxism but they talk about race 1619
critical race theory
diversity including training america
is a racist country mass is racist
how crazy is that two plus two equals
five yes
so number one rule for the
party i know this just like 1984 number
one rule
party is always right number two repeat
this same talking points every day even
though there are big lies
every day repeat it every day same time
everybody every media the lies
will become truth people will no longer
question
uh is united states learning from
chinese communist party tactics
why if they are taking their
hardcore tactics why we're going to ask
that question
i'm sorry
so american citizens
need to ask more questions and it
doesn't matter how
much you're afraid to be caught you are
racist thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you